okay changing of the gaurd time I think
I should probably say a few words word
has officially come down that Steven
Moffat will be leaving Doctor Who and no
longer running the show after the end of
the upcoming series which will be series
10 now I've actually been making a point
of avoiding going online and seeing what
people's reaction are to it but I can
I'm gonna hazard a guess that it's very
divided because Moffat himself and his
time as the showrunner has been very
divisive there are people who love it
there people who hate it for my part
I've got mixed feelings about this for
the most part I really like Moffat I
like a lot of what he brings to the
table I like the sorts of stories he
tends to emphasize I like most the
characters that he himself actually
created heck he wrote Heaven Sent which
you know this past series which is still
quite possibly my favorite episode of
Doctor Who ever but at the same time I'm
gonna openly admit that you know what
it's probably a good time for him to go
whether you like him or not
no one person should be in charge of
Doctor Who for too too long because one
of the many things that's great about
the show it's is it's adaptable nature
and obviously we see that you know the
face of that is when we get a
regeneration we get a new actor but the
behind the scenes change is also really
important to that because you if you
know enough about classic Doctor Who you
can divide up classic Doctor Who in a
couple of ways you can do it by doctor
or you can do it by showrunner because
you'll see the way that certain show
runners bring you know what they feel
are the best ways to direct the show and
you may agree or you may disagree but it
keeps changing and it keeps refreshing
so that's that's the non obvious visual
way that the show is able to refresh
yourself in addition to being able to
swap out the actor now I'm not gonna get
into a lot of the stuff that people do
or don't like about Moffat I mean I've
read a lot of the criticisms of Moffat
and while I don't personally share a
whole bunch of them I'm not gonna say
that they're invalid I've seen some very
good points made about the man just in
general and about his writing in
particular specifically on this show and
you know what they're valid criticisms
but for my part I have still really
enjoyed most of his time here I think
the main thing
that I'm hoping to get is to get someone
who's a little less in love with their
own creations I have seen that with
Moffitt we had a couple of points but
got with Clara
especially man I was so done with that
by the end but I'm not gonna rehash that
now we do know who's taking his place
and that's Chris Chibnall now I've got
some mixed feelings about him a little
bit I gotta be honest now he has one to
show before he's the showrunner for
broadchurch which I keep meaning to see
and I keep not getting around to it it's
one of the many things I might to do
list so I don't know how good that show
was I can't judge by that all I can
really judge is by his him his output as
a writer on Doctor Who and that has not
been great it's really I don't even want
to say a mixed bag it's a lower-tier
batch of episodes that he himself has
done I mean he started writing for the
show back away back to series 3 with 42
which is a ok episode the ticking clock
is kind of interesting there's some neat
ideas but it never really comes together
probably the best work he did was in
series 5 on the Silurian two-parter
which was pretty good but again not
exceptional not fantastic but it's like
that's a solid rehash for that kind of
character sure then on series 7 he did
dinosaurs on the spaceship which is
probably my personal favorite the Nero
which is a rip-roaring good time not a
lot of depth to it though and finally
the power 3 which I thought was fine but
I know a lot of people really hated and
while your mileage may vary on these
episodes I don't know really anybody off
the top of my head who ranks any of
these as favorite episodes and that kind
of makes me nervous now again without
getting to whether or not Moffitt's time
as showrunner was awesome or terrible or
some sort of mix his output prior to be
showrunner was kind of impeccable the
empty child the girl in the fireplace
silence in the library blink I mean
these were consistently some of the most
loved best rated episodes so having him
be the showrunner made perfect sense
I look at Chris Chibnall output and I
kind of go that being said I feel like a
lot of the things that were sort of
issues on his episodes were on the
conceptual level as opposed to the
writing level and it couldn't quite
possibly be that he was given a story
here right as an episode of this story
and he just made the best thing
I don't know if that's the case or not I
don't know enough about the
behind-the-scenes workings of Doctor Who
I get the feeling that there are some
writers who come in and do that sort of
thing they're given something to do and
others like like Neil Gaiman who can
basically come in and probably do their
own thing and of course the lingering
question is whether or not Peter Capaldi
is going to stay after Moffat leaves I'm
gonna say odds are probably not because
this coming up series is going to be his
third series and three series is the
most we've gotten out of any but well we
got a little bit more than that with
tenon because he stayed on for the
specials but sort of three full proper
series that's all that's the most we've
gotten out of modern era Doctor Who so
just statistically you kind of go yeah
you probably won't stick around I
personally would like him to but you
know he may be done with it by this
point he may feel he's done everything
that he's gonna do and if he wants to
move on you know it's about the time
pretty much everybody did but overall I
think it's an exciting time it makes me
excited for not only what's gonna happen
when we get in Chris Chibnall at the
helm and whether or not we get a new
doctor but also for upcoming series them
because you know it's not always the
case but often times creators get really
ballsy when they know they're wrapping
up and so I'm really gonna be kind of
interested and excited to see if
Moffitt's got anything like that left in
the tank
now Brant it's also possible that he's
just run out of steam and he's just
gonna coast through this last series I
don't think so though I certainly hope
not in any case but regardless Steven
Moffat leaving Doctor Who what are your
thoughts on this had to happen
eventually you happy
you said are you me kind of like it was
a good run but it's time for him to go
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it liked this video subscribe
to my channel find me on Twitter at
Council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcast on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned